jt brubacher takes the hill
making his second big league start now
reyes has not gone off to a slow start
uh he's the dh
he's hitting 316. five homers 15 rbis
1-0 pitch and swinging a ground ball
right to third and gonzalez on the
second to get the
out there and the inning is through so
uh an error and a walk and brubacher
no big deal cleans it right up carrasco
coming out trying to get in that win
column again in his last start
lost against the chicago cubs he walked
five
guys um so he's going to try and get
back on track
colin moran now he got off to a
strong start slowed down for a stretch
hit hard and into right field for colin
moran
despite the shift hit it too hard and
it's one nothing pirates
so polanco then eric gonzalez andrad
dyson
mixing carlos carrasco deep but foul
a long way that ball is most likely wet
you were right bob yeah you just tell us
close enough do you have a jump in there
it's not all that deep you got a net
oh he's going in after it it's too
important got to go in there and get it
yes have to get that foul ball how deep
do you think it is right there in that
spot i don't know
came back and got him carrasco's second
strikeout after the long
foul the pulse may be quickening a bit
for jt brubaker base is loaded nobody
out third inning
that ball sucked into right center field
that's going to get home the tying run
hernandez here comes ramirez
with the go ahead run and lindor goes
all the way to third
as carlos santana delivers with a
two-run single to give the indians the
lead
now friend male reyes that ball has hit
the deep center
gerard dyson on the move on the track he
makes the catch
crashing into the wall tagging and
scoring is lindor
and the indians have scored three times
here in the third
that was a heck of a play that
definitely if for right now kind of
saves this game i mean this looks like
it's ticketed for the wall
no problem chance to get out of trouble
if he can get gerard dyson who popped up
on the infield his first time up swung
on chops slowly to the second baseman
hernandez on to first
in time for the out and carrasco wiggles
out of the gym
francisco lindor on base for a third
time he walked
his first two times to the plate against
jt brubacher
hard hit and another outstanding play by
gonzalez he turns that into a double
play yeah a double into a double play
very nice he can pick it 108 miles an
hour off the bat
he's got that knack too uh making plays
look kind of ho-hum
golden opportunity for josh bell to just
throw one out there
find some grass and tie this thing up
and a swing and a line drive out to
right center he
scalded that ball it's going to go all
the way to the wall
and frazier is in newman scores
that's a josh bell special two-run
double the pirates have tied it at three
now they had to feel good and that will
deliver a knockout punch
but now chris stratton tyler naquin
gets a strikeout to begin the sixth
roberto perez on deck oh
brother now that's a challenge 10 almost
fell over backward
a couple of strikeouts in a row on
fastballs
turley looking for his first major
league win
entering in a tie game 3-3 7th inning
good work nick turley
ramirez very upset there's lindor
with two outs he swings and pops one up
to left
reynolds waits on this one to come down
and he makes the catch and the innings
over so
nick turley sends down cleveland
in the seventh inning karen czech has
been dynamite for the indians
swing and a bouncing ball headed to
first karen check gets moran to end the
seventh
in this game days tied at three
looking for the third out three and two
on hernandez on deck jose ramirez
and a chase and a scoreless top of the
night
you've got josh bell who drove in two
runs for the pirates in the fifth and
then on deck is colin moran who drove in
their other room
swing and a miss he struck him out with
a fastball and we've got extra innings
so now first and second and one out for
carlos santander that has two of the
three rbi's tonight
oh my if it's fair it's gone and
it is a home run
carlos santana with a towering three-run
homer
right over the foul pole down the left
field line
the pirates will no doubtedly challenge
this but for now anyway
it's a 6-3 indians lead he's sitting up
there
waiting for it he oh he started to walk
back just look at his reaction the
catcher murphy's shaking his head
but here's the ball uh is that going
over the top of the foul pole
no that's a phone it's behind here we go
yes indeed give that man a three-run
homer
and a 6-3 indians lead